[Music]
hey there welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories I'm AA and I'll be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and embark on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about mental health
awareness High School is a defining
period in a young person's life full of
transitions challenges and
opportunities while academic performance
has traditionally been the primary focus
the importance of mental health in high
school cannot be overstated by
recognizing the importance of mental
health we can foster a healthier
education environment the better
equipped students for their
future High School is a crial state in
the student educational journey and in
its back shows throughout their life at
this juncture the significance of mental
health in relation to academic
performance cannot be deied when
students grapple with mental health
issues like anxiety depression or stress
their scholis achievements are often the
first casualties the Relentless pressure
to excel academically compounding by
internal emotional structures can lead
to poor concentration abolism and a mark
declining grades
I'll be listening down some common
issues facing when dealing with
depression anxiety and stress
respectively as these are the most
common issues that occur advis not the
only ones depression depression is a
persuasive mental health condition that
can have severe repercussions for high
school students the effects of
depression can be profound and include
academic
performance depressed students often
struggle to concentrate and find it
challenging to complete assignment
just can leap to a Dro in grades
hindering their academic progress
social physical symptoms students with
depression may experience physical
symptoms like fatigue changes in
appetite and sleep disturbances these
symptoms can further affect their
ability to engage in school
activities emotional turmoil depression
can result in a persistent feeling of
sadness hopelessness and low
self-esteem this emotional turmoil can
make it very difficult for students to
engage in extracurricular activities and
affect their overall well-being risk of
self harm in severe cases depression can
lead to self Haring behaviors or
Suicidal Thoughts posing a significant
risk to the students life anxiety
anxiety is a common mental health
condition in high school students and
effects can be far-reaching it affects
academic performance anxiety often
leaves to procrastination and difficulty
focusing on tasks causing a decline in
academic performance physical symptoms
anxiety can manifest physically as
relentlessness muscle tension and even
panic attacks these symptoms can be
distressing and
destructive social isolations students
with anxiety May avoid social situations
or public speaking impacting their
ability to engage in extracurricular
activities or make
friends excessive worry chronic worrying
is a Hallmark of anxiety and it can
consume a student's thoughts making it
challenging to concentrate on school
work or enjoy extracurricular
activities impact on physical health
long-term anxiety can have severe
effects on physical health including
even digestive issues and weakened
immune
functions stress stress while a normal
part of life can become problematic when
excessive leading to a range of
consequences such as academic pressure
again the pressure to excel academically
can contribute to high levels of stress
in high school this can lead to burnout
reduced motivation and a decline in
performance physical health chronic
stress can result in physical symptoms
such as headaches muscle tension and
sleep disturbances impacting students
overall health emotional well-being high
levels of stress can lead to mood swings
irritability and a sense of being
overwhelmed a affecting in a students
emotional well-being and mental health
impact on
relationships stress can also strain
relationships with peers teachers and
family members as students may become
more irritable or
withdrawn also substance abuse some
students may turn to substance use as a
coping
mechanism which can lead to more severe
issues in the long term and High School
depression anxiety and stress can have
wide ranging
consequences impacting not only academic
performance but also emotional social
and physical
wellbeing recognizing the signs
providing support and offering resources
to address these challenges are
essential to promoting the mental health
and overall wellbeing of high school
students students contending with mental
health challenges often find it a Rus to
focus complete assignments and
participate actively in class by ad Jing
mental health issues in High School
Educational institutions create a more
conductive learning environment ensuring
that students have the resources and
report necessary to excel
academically in doing so the importance
of mental health in high school is
underscored as it directly correlates
with long-term educational success
High School is not only about academic
growth but also a time for forging
friendships building relationships and
developing social skills mental health
plays a significant role in these
aspects of high school life students who
are emotionally balanced and well
adjusted are more likely to engage in
healthy social interactions build
positive relationships and form a
support system with their peers on the
other hand students facing mental health
challenges often grapple with
difficulties in socializing which can
lead to feeling of isolation and
loneliness the importance of mental
health in high school becomes evident in
the context of promoting positive social
interactions and reducing the stigma
associated with discussing mental health
it encourages students to reach out to
their peers who might be grappling with
mental health issues and in turn this
promotes a cult culture of support and
empathy High School serves as a backdrop
for personal growth and future success
but it is also a Time marked by
vulnerability and emotional turbulence
recognizing the importance of mental
health during these format of years is
critical for students overall wellbeing
mental health challenges can manifest
the stress anxiety as depression as
mentioned before but even more severe
conditions failing to address these
issues can have longlasting consequences
on the students's
wellbeing and this extends even to their
adult lives in this context the
significance of mental health and high
school experience Encompass the broader
well being of students your mental
health is overlooked or stigmatized
students may carry unresolved emotional
challenges into their adult lives this
can result in long-term impacts and even
impact their Career Success personal
relationships and just generally their
entire Quality of Life by addressing
mental health issues during high school
we not only improve the immediate
well-being of students but then also set
them on a path towards a healthier and
more fulfilling
adulthood in conclusion the significance
of mental health in high school is
immense it directly influences academic
performance social interaction is an
overall wellbeing high schools are a
pivotal role in creating an environment
where students are encouraged to seek
help and engage in open conversations
about mental health by prioritizing this
high schools Empower their students to
overcome challenges to develop
resilience and ultimately lead healthier
and more fulfilling lives acknowledging
the importance of mental health in high
school is not only a matter of
educational well-being but it is a
fundamental step towards nurturing a
more emotionally resilient and
productive future
generation contributing to their
lifelong well-being the holistic
approach to education must Encompass the
mental health of students recognizing
the academic success and personal growth
are instinctively linked to such
psychological stabil ability high
schools can lead the way of fostering
culture or
empathy understanding and open
Communications around mental health and
by doing so they lay New Foundations for
a healthier and more resilient Society
where individuals are better equipped to
cope with the challenges to live and
thrive in life in addressing mental
health high schools are not only
nurturing the minds of future but also
safeguarding the emotional wellbeing of
generations to
come thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible journey and
we're so glad you came along for the
ride remember mental health awareness is
not a topic to be taken lightly let's
keep the conversation going break the
stigma and support each other in our
Journeys towards better mental health
until next time take care
[Music]